hi guys scifi recap here
before we start
warning spoilers ahead today i'm gonna
explain a 2015 american science fiction
movie called tomorrowland
the movie begins with frank walker
recording himself and telling a story
about the future he states that the
future can be scary and with every
second that passes by they are getting
closer and closer to the end of the
world
back to 1964 a young frank attends new
york world's fair while carrying a big
heavy bag he meets david nix renowned
inventor and jury in the competition and
shows him a jet pack he created he
explains how he built the machine to him
but he is not impressed suddenly a girl
named athena comes and is interested in
the idea finding that frank is a
motivated and hardworking kid however
even though the jetpack allows its users
to fly it is still uncontrollable and
still needs to be refined david asks him
how a jetpack would make the world a
better place frank replies that it would
give hope inspiration and motivation to
others because anything is possible
unfortunately the jury rejects his idea
because it still cannot be used and
sends him out in a brief flashback
frank's dad also thought that the
jetpack would be useless and told him
not to waste his time but frank was
still optimistic outside the hall athena
approaches the frustrated frank and
hands him a pin with a t printed on it
she tells him to follow her and nicks
into it's a small world right
frank chases after her and manages to
sneak onto a boat
when the boat reaches the tunnel eliza
spots and scans the pin on his shirt
taking him through an underground
passageway he gets into a pod which
transports him into a futuristic
cityscape
he steps out of the pod and sees athena
is waving at him in a flying pod
suddenly several robots appear and push
frank and his jetpack off the ledge he
meets a robot that manages to fix his
jetpack and gives frank a thumbs up
after that two technicians confront the
kid causing him to fall again
luckily the jet pack has been fixed and
works perfectly fine saving him from
death he flies and explores the city
getting a brief look at the futuristic
utopia he has been led to
he spots athena and lands in front of
nyx but he is still not impressed
she grabs frank's hand and introduces
him to a paradise known as tomorrowland
back to the recording scene frank is
also accompanied by casey an optimistic
girl who starts to share her own story
casey is a smart girl as she managed to
memorize all major stars in the sky when
she was a child she claimed that she
wants to go there somewhere
in the present casey sneaks into nasa
demolition site uses a drone to hack the
cctv and sabotages three cranes that
will be used to demolish the platform
preventing her father from losing his
job however her actions are secretly
monitored by a little girl that turns
out to be athena casey returns home and
sneaks in through the window her little
brother
nate spots her and promises not to tell
their dad what casey's been up to athena
secretly picks a strand of casey's hair
and synchronizes it with an identical
pin that was previously given to frank
the next day we discovered that casey's
dad eddie is actually a nasa engineer
and tells casey that nasa is taking down
that platform and it is inevitable he
also adds that they are bringing in
replacement cranes for the ones she
broke the earlier night later in the
night casey attempts to sneak in and
sabotage the replacement cranes again
however they are now more prepared the
security guard captures the drone and
casey is arrested luckily she gets
released and she goes to collect her
stuff
she spots the t-bin among her stuff
which she has never seen before
when casey touches it the world around
her suddenly alters into a wheat field
which shocks her
she picks the pin back and discovers a
futuristic city from a distance she
tries to walk towards it only to bump
her head onto the ceiling eddie is very
angry and picks her up from the police
station on their way home she shows her
father the pen and tells him about its
magic but nothing happens when eddie
touches it and he takes the pin away
from casey
that night casey sneaks into her
father's room and takes the pin back
she takes her bike and goes towards the
direction of the futuristic city
she arrives at the empty field and
touches the pin again she eventually
finds himself in the center of
tomorrowland
casey starts exploring the city and goes
to a tesla station where she meets a
robot girl who is able to see her and
interact with her as the train arrives
she follows an astronaut girl who later
invites casey to join her in a space
expedition as casey walks towards them
the time on the pin runs out sending her
back to reality where she is walking
through a swamp
casey runs back home and asks nade to
log into their dad's pc they eventually
find a shop that is willing to buy the
pin and she asks nade to tell their dad
that she went on a camping trip the next
day while casey is on her way to the
shop athena shows up at casey's house
and meets nate
he lies to her when he is asked about
casey but she reveals that she is from
the future and forces nate to tell the
truth
casey arrives and shows the shop owners
hugo and ursula the pen they urge her to
tell them who gave the pin to her she
insists that she doesn't know and the
pair start talking about a girl who
casey has never met before that she has
no idea who she is and is confused casey
tries to leave but they suddenly take
out two plasma guns and aim them at her
casey attempts to hide but eventually is
cornered by the couple
just before they shoot her athena comes
and throws a time bomb which stops time
for a short duration
she convinces casey to follow her and
she agrees athena manages to knock the
pair out and they escape from there
before the pair would turn out to be
robots self-destruct they then go away
from the city with a stolen car
casey learns that athena is a recruiter
and is also a robot casey purposely hits
the brake causing athena to be hit by
another car she then steals the car and
attempts to escape from her but athena
manages to catch up and tells her that
she gave her the pin
she adds that tomorrowland is real and
needs casey's help to save the dying
futuristic city
long story short athena drops casey in
frank's house and leaves upon arrival
she is welcomed by a fierce dog which
turns out to be a hologram
she shows the pin to the camera on the
door but gets thrown back by a powerful
blast
frank then comes out and tells her to go
away revealing that what she saw earlier
was a commercial that was recorded
decades ago
however casey does not give up and sets
frank's tractor on fire distracting him
so that she can sneak into his house and
locks frank outside casey finds a
recording device that shows the child
version of frank trying to make athena
laugh but failed
at that time he didn't seem to know that
athena was a robot
frank eventually manages to get back
into his house as casey discovers his
work room
he reveals that he was thrown out of
tomorrowland by nyx because he built a
machine that could predict the future to
be exact to predict when the world ends
with 100 accuracy
frank gives up and accepts the reality
but casey believes that there is
something that can be done which causes
the 100 on the screen to go down a few
points
frank is surprised but suddenly a group
of robots who try to eliminate frank and
catch athena show up and break into the
house frank is prepared as he already
planted a lot of traps in the house
they eliminate the robots and run
towards the bathroom hopping into a
bathtub which turns out to be an escape
pod
the pod lands on a lake as the house
explodes
athena suddenly arrives to pick them up
however frank seems upset when he sees
her they arrive at an office where
frank's teleportation machine is kept
underneath the office they get into a
teleport pod where frank covers casey's
eyes with black sheet and forces her to
consume powder as athena sets their
destination to the eiffel tower
upon arrival casey is surprised when she
finds herself at the top of eiffel tower
they knock out a guard and get into a
room where mannequins of gustav eiffel
jules vern nicola tesla and thomas
edison are present they are co-founders
of plus ultra a secret organization that
invented tomorrowland
frank activates the spectacle a one-way
ticket for them to go to tomorrowland
suddenly a huge space plane appears in
the middle of eiffel tower however the
robots from frank's house arrive and
chase after them they managed to get
into the space plan and launch it into
the sky on time before the robots reach
the plane
the pod containing three of them goes
back to the earth but into another
dimension
they land and casey finally steps into
the real tomorrowland for the first time
upon arrival frank hands over a bomb to
athena and they are welcomed by nix who
has now become the governor of the city
frank tells him that casey can fix the
monitor the machine that can predict the
future he takes them to it by using a
platform that can show events from a few
seconds in the future using tachyons
they arrive at the monitor where it can
show events in a certain time in this
case when casey was talking to his dad
after sabotaging the cranes she then
sets the device into the future which
shows the nasa platform is being
destroyed she then travels all around
the world with the device and sees riots
and natural disasters indicating that
the world is ending this is happening
because of the machine frank built and
unfortunately nyx and frank have also
given up however casey still refuses to
believe the reality shown by the monitor
offering another glimpse of hope
a few minutes later casey realizes that
the monitor does not show events that
will happen but what could happen
she then suggests to turn the monitor
off so it will not share false hope to
other people however nix already
prepares a device to transport them back
to the real world and refuses to shut
the monitor down he reveals that he had
shown the apocalypse generated by the
monitor to the people as a warning
instead they embraced it and refused to
change their behavior to make the world
a better place causing him to believe
that humanity had given up and allowed
the apocalypse to happen
frank athena and casey fight back and
refuse to be sent to the real world
while battling knicks frank orders the
girls to go to the monitor and destroy
it with the bomb
casey manages to get onto the platform
while athena is fighting the huge robots
unfortunately casey misses her chance to
throw the bomb and is brought down back
to the hall
because the bomb can't be deactivated
casey throws the bomb to the real world
through the portal and it explodes on an
uninhabited island
nix attempts to shoot frank which athena
sees moments before it happens causing
her to jump in and take the shot herself
frank immediately brings her to a repair
module but she knows there is not enough
time
thus before she is shutting down she
shows a recording of when frank was
still a child and she realized that
frank was smitten by her but she kept
the truth that she was a robot and
couldn't feel love because she didn't
want to damage frank's potential
finally she suggests frank to use her
self-destruct sequence to destroy the
monitor
frank carries her with his jetpack up to
the monitor
before he drops athena she says her
final goodbye
she then explodes and destroys the
entire system
after the incident
frank and casey decide that they can
shape the future into a better world
casey returns home through the portal
and recruits nate and eddie while frank
is mass producing the t-pin
they then recruit other kids and give
all the pins to them sending them to
various places around the world
the kids then hand over the pin to
people who are worthy and have hope in
their lives
or in other word the dreamers
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching